yeah okay but it reminds me this one
connects to like the deal Olympics more
so than some of the other ones we're
just checking and make sure that you
guys can hear and/or see us did we go -
and we're back
maybe well hey we should be okay though
I don't know if we were here for the
past three to five minutes but if not
hey how are you in case you guys have
missed the last minute or so sorry we
are missing our resident stream expert
Eric Tay he's missing in action but
we're here I think let us know in the
comments below if we're here and you can
hear us and you've seen some skins or if
we just showed up anyway Joey currently
has a hundred and one loot boxes I see
it in the comments which means they can
see it so I will be opening them for
sure are we gonna open all 100 in one
sitting or we gonna open like 50 then
play then like no you and just blew all
your load like right away you want I
mean a saver like at least half of it
first okay I'm seeing some comments that
there are skins that we haven't seen yet
wait you mean the ones that weren't
shown in the in a gallery yeah I really
go one by one actually key quickly go to
road hog in the comments just baited me
and I fell for it man I was kind of
excited I saw speedo road hog and I was
like yes that's that's their wish right
nothing for Reinhardt let me see the
ones that no oh a somber did summer got
something yeah all right let's look
Symmetra nothing Torbjorn now he's got
the old one he's gotten too many
skinflint tracer oh this might be the
only weight I bet the old yeah this is
the only event where she hasn't gotten a
new one yeah that's that's unprecedented
well she had gotten two new skins during
the first one yeah so it would make
sense for
this is a good opportunity if you missed
her awesome skin last time Oh who's
arias yes arias was the you know the
Wonder yeah like a both of them actually
yeah those are pretty cool let us know
in the comments if you guys are live on
ps4 Xbox I'm not sure we're playing on
PC today so I don't know if we're live
did doofus get any finger now because
this would be his first opportunity yeah
no no yeah it's probably like it was it
was a case where they were developing
this at the same time as doom fist so
they didn't really have time to do that
but I heard some people in the chat
wanting to go on uh uh Widow to I don't
think we should
okay so we got honor no no skins I'll go
through like the highlight reels and
emotes in a second or highlight intros
mercy though she's got one Mercy's is
sick you know the Greek Mercy's mercy is
the only one of the group that kind of
ties back into like the Greek mythology
actual Olympics yeah uh you know maybe
the Olympics were real they weren't
myths well yeah that stuff is one of the
other things that somebody mentioned was
I think Reaper did right oh yes Reaper
interest in this is Reapers right here
this was a little weird to me I I really
like this one I don't know why but like
I think I might just be like the helmet
I don't know felt like really really
yeah motorcycle themed and everything I
don't know it's the they're like full I
wish that you could see his face in the
helmet I wish it wasn't like the skull
you know what I mean we mean like his
human face yeah yeah like Reyes well I
mean I think this one is the only one
that should have it because this is
before this is like before he's Reaper
so you say this was you got like a
terrible motorcycle accident that's why
he's
okay so Barra has a highlight intro that
I'm I know that a lot of people like
called slam dunk whoops that's awesome
man I wish she got like a basketball
outfit yeah yeah how would you how would
she fly she would need all the UH
basketball shorts but at least someone
get like a basketball jersey and like
shorts that would be sick okay well
speaking of shorts we got
it's called grill master 76 the grill
master show oh I didn't even see the
shirt you see shirt racing so looking at
this closely he's got an apron right
here so he's he's dressed in the dead 76
like outfit with the oh the songs and
sandbox socks and sandals
he's got beer cans right here or those
spices no no I assume those what he
places down as the the healing beacon
he's got a spatula and tongs and then
his weapon right here oh my god
assault assault rifle oh my god I notice
waiting the coils at the end of the gun
use like an old-timey like look at
microwave ovens sometimes had those
right all right it's just like the it's
like more of a copper one yea the coils
and then there's like the part like a
propane tank here the temperature gauge
oh man that's a good that's a good one
well McCree macri's just a close second
i think Deva get anything no right I
don't believe so
TV's a fan favorite but no no sorry I
know we got sambar here I know so I
heard somebody asking about that we got
it's called to loom which is uh looks
like a snorkeling outfit she's got like
flippers right here she has the she has
via little oxygen tank like in the back
and the snorkel does anyone know what
the direct translation of that is Tulum
well you can look it up
you got the Internet I'm gonna actually
look at her fingertips did to see what
that actually means so we got her gun
which there are guns okay it's not like
super different I don't think so nice I
like that shade of green though English
Tulum maybe it's a place Oh people I see
let's see who was asked for junk rat 20
Rico 12 I guess we did we got that one
in the beginning but we might very why
you got he's it's a cricket outfit so
he's got the cricket helmet do people
wear helmets or the doll when they're at
bat
yes oh yeah you're at bat they they wear
cuz those that'll like mess you up
it's those crazy yeah those are hard so
he's got like I assume he like shoots
them out of his gun
yeah balls like if he's got like a
little couple nails in his cricket bat
leg right here those games like
traditionally last for like days and
weeks um yeah oh yeah they are there so
this is the cricket ball launcher and
everything you know how to play cricket
no no idea like all I know is that you
have to defend the wickets with the bat
and then if you hit it someone can catch
it it's not as far as I like baseball
that's what I know
all right we got we're getting a lot of
demands here for Widowmaker with makers
oh yeah I think that's the only one that
we haven't gone to you well I know
people have been asking for like a good
skin because like her current ones are
just kind of man there you go though
look at this she is ready for the beach
yes a day at the beach it's got the Sun
glass of the the look at the hair though
I was gonna say I think the sunglasses
my favorite part they I don't know look
at the hair it's like not braids is not
like you know like a ponytail or
anything like that like this one or
knows that this one is like that what's
too crazy yeah like this one looks nice
what's your weapon look like
oh thank you so much Jimmy I was like we
like driftwood no it's a normal weapon
for her outfit which is kind of weird
buzzer at all I'm sure that means
something if we translate it yeah this
is this looks good is this a zit the
seagulls and everything I'm assuming
this is everyone's favorites too many
thirsty people well come on look at this
this is this is like the first widows
skin that's like it's different yeah
it's like it's like very unique compared
to the other ones they're like they're
all just like you know just like a
hunter obviously and then this one's
just I always thought this one was kind
of strange
like the ballerina yeah I think that
cool I think the coolest one we'd had
was was that one the town yeah the
uprising yeah I don't know it's like a
secret agent but this one yeah but this
was all good one let's see if anyone in
the chattin knows of like the highlight
intros I'm gonna kind of go into them
see if we can find a couple good ones
maybe doofus has a highway through no
I'm surprised he didn't get anything
emos no I know there are a bunch of
sprays I saw a bunch of sprays and like
oh yeah that's that's a lot to get
through at this point Oh someone that's
for McCree might have cut that one off
too but yeah he's got this is funny
that's the one I've liked I've been
waiting for like this year to come back
around so I could get the USA one now I
don't even want it yeah no one wants
this one because you got the lifeguard
one too like why would you not that's
the best one I thought it's like a
little bit a little bit thicker a little
buffer well I mean overall he's kind of
a slender man right like because he's
got like the baggy pants baggy jeans
let's look at his weapon the desert
eagle that's a flare launcher I wonder
if it like the actual shots are any
different I don't know it was I'm not
sure how much like they changed the
animation for some of these things it
might be time to open some loop boxes
and maybe we'll get it don't buy it
though because that's the one time I did
this with tagging we open some loot
boxes
he bought one and in the very next leaf
box was the one that he got yeah it's
it's high time that's been in the chat
oh it's a high tide then all right so I
guess we are gonna open I'm not gonna go
I have a hundred and one loop boxes
right now I'm not gonna open all 50 of
them what would I guess what we can do
is open or not open all of them we'll go
go 51st maybe okay and then we'll play
some matches we'll play some Lucille
Ball
Lucille Ball okay maybe get some
whatever skins that we have we'll put
them on go jump into a game and then
we'll come back open the rest of them
see what our luck brings us this time
around I like it okay you ready
let's do it first one round one are we
gonna get luck oh nothing you know well
that's the worst that's the word that's
buing right there well we did get a new
remote which is the one from last from
last year yeah okay also I noticed that
this is this is after the the new patch
were they got rid of a lot of the
duplicates oh really like all your loop
box is going forward will most likely
not contain like as many duplicates as
it used to because before it would be
like but but instead you're only gonna
get Gold's that are not applicable to
the event I don't mind that I mean as
long as it's not a duplicate like it's
make my time worth it here all right
look at that node oops yeah so we got
spray that's my favorite spray yeah I
love Gul moss you gave me that sticker
it's on my desk okay I think this one's
new they all got like the victory pose
with the
the metals like this one he said oh yeah
they turned it to the vault volumes
slightly lower I noticed that it's kind
of loud there we go look at that node
oops again yeah all right let's go Wow
nice actually pretty impressive I didn't
expect it to be this good oh you like
that one yeah I spent like an hour last
week just going through and just
listening to look at that I think that
might be a new one
never mind no I thought the the sparks
that came out during that was meant it
was a new summer game zone but look at
that though every single thing that you
just got is all summer game has not ooh
wow that's nice BMX yeah now yeah it
would have been said yes so I think when
the first summer games came around it
was like remember the sticker set that
they sent out yeah it had stuff like
Reaper in a bicycle but they didn't have
a skin attached to it and now that they
have they actually followed through with
it which is really cool
have you yet to get a duplicate no I
haven't gotten dupe yet so their system
is working out really well I'm really
excited all sudden I think I'm more
excited about the non dupe thing then I
am about the up yeah so far so good
yeah see else you might need me when is
this coming out ps4 it I'm not sure if
it's like it but if not you can you know
you can maybe just restart it you know
you're gonna wanna you're gonna want to
shut down your ps4 completely like do a
heart not just sleep mode
and then try to hop back in that's what
I usually do it my death
yeah cuz you you play mainly on console
I'm yeah me on PC so we're we are
playing on PC right now so if you have
like ps4 Xbox one just try that and see
if it works yeah but let us please you
guys if you're trying to get in on Xbox
or Playstation let us know in the chat
so we can kind of let people know and if
you guys have any questions for Joey
toss them in the chat I'm watching both
twitch YouTube and the site chat so let
me know if you have any questions
alright we're doing really good with no
duplicates but a single skinny ya knows
how many how many we gone through so go
through 11 okay 90 more to go let's see
mamsi 97 says I've already done that no
cigar
so I guess ps4 is still in the works
Angela said she's restarting her xbox so
many times don't know luck and we're
having no luck I know with skins I mean
there's a lot of voice lines these are
pretty cool maybe they lowered the
chance of duplicates or maybe they yeah
lower chance of duplicates but also
lower the chance of skins is this a
pillow oh that's a good I like that oh I
get when you just spray the pillow
underneath them alright come on
legendary
a lot of blue and white symmetric man I
just saw someone really quickly say they
were playing on console Oh shifty gr
says North American ps4 just got through
congratulations
I know some people are also stuck in oh
we got a legendary put that one on all
right all right we got one group etched
onto his butt right there um I'm gonna
log in here our resident Twitter expert
she would just sent me the periscope oh
oh back-to-back goal that's fine wait do
we get oh you've got that was that new I
think that at all yeah that's sick
that's a good one now I just need to get
play the game as hanzo says going
through maintenance right now so if some
of you can't get through just you know
give it a couple minutes
yeah be a while frost says frost says is
purple or yellow litter it is yellow
well gold yeah gold yeah let's purple is
what it is
oh this one I've been waiting for the
slit
what is that look at that's exactly what
it is yeah oh that's nice she wouldn't
have been around during the first summer
yawns all right 81 okay got the got the
wheel in ah come on with these non-event
goals yeah daddy dragon blaze is asking
is the nihon back the Genji skin so if
you guys played the first summer games
back then last year they are bringing
all those skins back in these loot boxes
in addition to all the new ones as well
you know it's another questions I don't
remember like how expensive the old ones
were in the first place versus how it
stuff that they are now the thing is
when they release them you weren't able
to buy them oh do you remember that like
last year that this was before they
implemented the like the extra gold for
like timely skins were back then you
could only get them from the loot boxes
and I remember people just being really
upset about because they they played
like I don't know or they spent like so
much money on the loot boxes or they
they spent like hours and hours and
hours just playing as much as I can and
they still couldn't get it so I think
the system that they have now is
actually pretty good like it still makes
it kind of worth it to to buy them so it
must be cheaper because it's purple well
I'm not hmm that's a good question
actually I think it might only be a
thousand but this traditionally those
are 750 but I think for events they
might be yeah I'll have to check like
the only thing later or how many we go
two epochs took a lot of people are
still trying to get into games have you
gotten a dupe yet no I haven't that's
pretty amazing
like it just goes to show you how much
stuff is actually in this game or maybe
these are all duplicates and they've
just not like they're just not giving me
gold
that would be messed up that would be
really many people think that they're
they're not getting duplicates some ps4
players got in there it's a long wait
yeah like just getting in there
immediately it's gonna take some time we
had that problem a couple times in the
past where we got booted and tried to go
back in and there's like 8,000 people in
front of us and me neither
so give me more skins legendaries please
[Music]
hit like yeah how do you differentiate
this dupe got some gold from that you
zoom out zoom out the dupe the duplicate
the way it signifies it is a lot subtler
than used to be yeah cuz it used to it
used to glow gold and usually sure
anyway it would say like +10 they're
like plus 15 for what you got also it's
kind of tricky I think it's I think it's
just very small and we think that we
haven't got that many well well no you
would at least hear the the gold coin
yeah getting getting a little bit closer
to our 50 yeah 68 left oh boy
so some people are asking how we're
we're already playing the update we are
playing on PC so I guess it came to PC
first
it sounds that gets out on consoles but
it's slowly rolling out oh wait oh is
that the best yeah yeah I'm dunk em yeah
I like that one I wish she got a Summer
Games outfit play nice play far off
looks like mr. e we'll all right who
said that mr. e 2m long sorry they've
changed the old event cost another
allowing you to buy the old event skins
for the normal price
yeah that's 150 and a thousand yeah so
if you guys missed any of the old summer
skins from last year that was about
now's the best time to get but Bob Jones
is saying
however the box is treating us not so
good it's all right yeah
yeah I don't know I feel like they've
lowered the chance for gold
yeah that's quiet now I was trying to
use reverse psychology what was that oh
okay he has that really cool emote with
the boxing gloves yeah I have that one
actually it was like Sock'em oh there we
go
I don't play mercy a lot but this is
actually a really good skin look at that
I wonder when she alts if the things the
fans out yeah I assume so I wonder if
she has a different voice line though
because in all the other in some of the
other skins you know it changes the
voice line for her like I also wonder if
that happens to any of the other
characters with their new legendaries
yeah come on soldier please sorry dude
tastes sec you're gonna have to deal
with me so the beat the B Squad is here
covering for ten
Oh where's this one yeah that's just
normal
oh my god so many shrugs yeah you've
gotta come on we've gotten some doing
the math here I think we've gotten two
gold summer skins with it and that's
awesome and three gold regular skins
though right but come on we got this
this is worth it
yeah this is worth every penny and then
I assume the ball continues to go on
from there all right let's keep going
Bob wants to know how many skins are we
missing a lot a lot of skin we've only
gotten to you to the legendaries there
we go and equip this for him and
hopefully this maybe this will help me
get his skin you want that's good yeah I
think it looks cool
this one no this suit even though this
but the suit this the tuxedo fist put on
over another loop box here
yeah nothing
oh that's new Sombra nope five more to
go in this session we're gonna move on
to some Lucille Ball and then we're at
least one of the new skins that we got
see what they look like no a lot of
people are saying they're waiting in
server queues be patient you'll get in
there I promise Oh gold so we can buy
them Fayette is trying to get you to buy
them so that when you buy more or when
you open up more boxes gold legendary
golden epic gold thanks guys yeah this
is what 150 and then is it 250 or 300
for legendaries close to being enough no
but what's the worst of that is if you
get a duplicate of a legendary it only
gives you what like it's kind of low
this one gets 15 okay that was old oh
shoot I think I passed the limit we are
off 50 but whatever okay this will be
the last one for now make sure I put
those on the junk run one you go I think
I put on Mercy's right yeah so we can go
into arcade we got 3v3 Lucille Ball we
got oh this is our ranked Lucille Ball
really yeah so these as you get the big
so you can play a ranked Lucille Ball
and that will actually influence your
your season ranking like just from it
like that's pretty that's I don't know
if I would do that that's yeah it's like
because it's totally different ball game
like if you've been fighting and working
on your life
I know or if you're really good at
Lucille Ball then yeah it might be might
be good way booster booster numbers
Lucille Ball isn't my favorite event
game they've done it's not my favorite I
think it's cool but it's definitely not
one of my what
favorite so far I really like the
Halloween one I like junk junk and
Steen's revenge oh yeah I guess we could
touch on that that that's kind of new
what
so last year during the Summer Games
it was bright outside yeah so this one
is in Sydney Harbor it's not where does
it last time it was in oh is it also
Sydney I think it was where who
remembers where the elliptical Olympics
were where they lost oh oh please it
thank you don't forget you can wall ride
this is Summer Olympics I was in Rio Rio
okay yeah so it has to be I guess it was
Brazil right oh yeah because Oh Lucille
Ball there you go because he's so now
we're in Sydney but it's at night which
is kind of cool come on
hey where to go oh you go super fast oh
sorry
whoa that's that yes your uncle thank
you I should be going faster I've got a
thousand pounds to say Rihanna and I
believe the next Summer Olympics will be
[Music]
is it Russia are you sure summer I think
so
isn't I know I got my way and that pulls
it towards you doesn't know it I think
they change it I think it just speeds
everyone know oh I got it oh it gives
you unlimited bumps oh wow
last year I pulled it towards you it was
like a oats in Tokyo for the summer
games the winter yeah oh come on someone
score Jesus oh my good is because that
that a good man is like just playing
goalie the whole time
defense defense I gotta remember to wall
ride because that's like oh where to go
if you guys missed some of the skins
earlier you're on YouTube you can scrub
back go in check out a lot of it jazzy
Oh open go damn it Joey an open go come
on oh no ok I got I gotta make sure the
wall right wow that was a sick say dang
where's the ball going the cross from
Joey is yeah that wasn't me Oh Super
Grover did you cross it though you're
gay I have no idea what is crossing well
we can watch a replay there's me doing
absolutely nothing
boom go at least we got a score let's
see what we got guys
I'm looking at console yet
I remember a lot of the comments last
year is that this is this this is like
very similar to rocket leap
yeah I mean I think the inspiration
behind at least I think it's just the
ball that looks like it I don't think I
mean I guess we gotta use these jump
heads more and ball riding right here go
all the way around
oh [ __ ] Joey's trying to look fancy
goals going also we just like riding
around
oh [ __ ] oh you don't stop well you can't
close yeah I was over there I was like
that guy's playing goalie you guys got
hot defense don't get very alright here
we go oh I can't do that please watch it
I hear that music get it the Beast wants
to know is this competitive it's not it
can be though but it can't be
competitive which is not an option last
year we are super fast right now
push it Oh wide left over time
Oh to you Gary says is anyone else like
the soldier 76 again no please no no no
no no I don't want to say he was out of
position but he was there the whole game
GG all right
salty runback salty runback good
this first one yeah they're just sweet
ricocheted yeah yet for saves in do you
guys think the guy on the left looks
like Tom Hall that's that's spider-man
new spider-man oh no I don't
looks like a lot of people Gandalf is in
the queue 10,000 people in front of him
Elizabeth July 20,000 oh wait we got a
new loop box by the way yeah now we're
at 50
so Jordan Richmond says did they change
the old yes in there in last year's
Lucille Lucille Ball uh the old would
bring the ball towards you it was like
you were a magnet and you'd be able to
like you know if you were like close to
the goal you could bring it towards you
and then just shoot it in yeah now they
have it speeds you up and you get
unlimited of bumps with your with your
gun Justin wants us to go to the skins
if you missed it if you missed the skin
go ahead and scrub back earlier if
you're on YouTube you can see we change
fields I think we're in Rio
yeah we're in Rio oh my god Wow Wow
he's waving wait let me jump right over
there ready watch this right boom oh he
hit it up I should probably do that more
often Laza
a Joey's current skin is the jazzy the
jazzy Lucille from the anniversary right
yeah it's a good one that's why you hear
those uh those horns every time okay I
don't play goalie back here come on
does anyone have any other questions or
concerns for Joey here again we're
playing on PC
and for those of you who are used to it
come on we stream pretty much every
single day here on GameSpot at 11 a.m.
please this is only wow that was close
we don't forget to like and subscribe if
you guys are on YouTube site don't
follow us follow we have a lot of great
content that comes out every single day
around 11 a.m.
save it oh my god have no idea please
know why this is of course join okay
yeah yeah
is this out on PC yes this is that's
we're playing on let's see
Eng got no new skin sorry effect Roenick
on ps4 Christian Jones is asking I'm not
sure if it's ready to go let's go I feel
a lot of people are either in queue
xored so updating any new emotes yeah
there get that in there oh my god
there's a beach ball you know or just
kind of funny please no skins for Genji
no skins for Hanzo I'm going after that
ball Kyle Miller wants to know DTrace
are getting new skins she did not I
think it's because she got to last time
I figured she owed you clear it had a
bunch for this event but I know Joey was
missing that actually this is the first
event tracer has come to the air
periscope chat to say what's up to all
our friends there mr. Q oh it's enough
summer got a new skin she did take a
snorkeling scuba divers skin weirdo I
don't know what the theme I think it's
just like it's summer food
merci however did get a skin and Joey
got it it's a loose body so we'll be
sure to play with that later in in there
we go
15 seconds left side up to tie it and
Bend
okay I also have my old at least no road
hog skin sorry guys this was your goal
yes
yes that was mine yes it looks like
legal game says tracer didn't get the
Halloween event yeah you're right okay
almost everyone or ally at the very
least she has the most skiing out of
everyone and again symmetric did
nominees skin Bastion did not and
neither GG
you gotta win once because you get it
for a good one that last one right no he
lost why they still get a loot box then
I don't know I was wondering that what
am i just like do I just have the
experience with something am I've ended
Seth wants no fair got one nope sorry
no she gets Kim but she did get a
highlight intro which I actually got way
doing it
yes yeah I did get him dunk this one
didn't
I saw someone asking for skins to show
at least one of them I thought I was
gonna take a little short break I don't
remember what if someone said people
wanted to see let me jump to a cue real
quick
we're playing Lucy ball yeah I'll do one
more and then maybe we can go into the
regular matches and then we can open up
more loot boxes
a lot of people keep saying that they're
20,000 people in front of them in the
queue yeah I've that's bonkers I've done
that before
well I think it was last time or maybe
the uprising one where we got stuck in
the queue and I think that's when we
brought you in it's crazy to complete it
oh yeah yeah that was a good time wanna
know why because you guys get to buy the
loot boxes on my account yeah
[Music]
hang in there oh [ __ ] sorry a rung goal
almost no face that when's the update
come out it should be out on everything
now depends on whether you yeah well I
should watch this this one was good I
think he's lost a month ago I went above
and then I was like no back up
nice let's get some let's get some nice
likes for that hot goal let's see did
Hanzo have a highlight intro I think he
did yeah you have a new one yeah I think
it's him but splitting the arrow arrow
and it splits this is basically what it
looks like when I play rocket League by
the way Joey trying to keep this game
close so you trying to get a couple long
goals where they'll jazz for the fish if
you want to check out the skins and
you're on YouTube just scrub back a
little bit towards the beginning this I
gotta use the walls to ride more because
it's so much faster than running those
pads are pretty helpful
alright
sorry guys but yeah if your is ninja and
everybody asking for skins to scrub back
towards the beginning of the stream
you'll see all all the cool skins like
Reaper the dare fight skin oh we just
keep pushing it back where is it all
right in here oh really
wow I thought that was in for sure
I think if Jamie wants to know what is
our favorite skin from this oh no no no
no it's just going straight there just
volleying it back and forth if I pick my
favorite skin from this update I'm gonna
go with soldier real master 7 really
good I think Joey's is probably McCree
shirtless lifeguard machree
good question from Jason Ross what day
does it end they typically last for how
many weeks I think like two to two to
three depending on the event we are
playing on the PC
Joey's playing the mouse of keyboard
please defend defend 53 seconds book
currently one nil the KitKat the KitKat
says the server's our consoles are being
a pretty bad
oh there should be an update right now
so hopefully that's a good sign
you guys will get in ASAP if you're a PC
though Oh No
Leila says the 28m so we got this one in
the bag
winner he gets he gets the loop box here
that'll make 51 16 seconds left
good oh wow that was disrespectful what
how did he do that he just went straight
for and went boom all right remember
that he's used to do that I was sick so
we sold 12 seconds slow
he's gonna do it again is he okay
somebody get a stroke you're on it I'll
leave
again wow that guy's really good he
actually should play this competitive
here for seconds can he do it
oh it's not him
oh alright well we'll go back to the
skins after this one
oh that's look at that shot nice I like
that we don't need to see alright so we
want to go to some of the skins we'll
just go like over quickly what the ones
that we yeah remembered so there was a
junk rat one which I got it's pretty
good cricket junk rat still trying to
figure out what it is on his back any of
you guys in the comments section maybe
your you play cricket or you're from an
area where cricket is more popular
wickets that like you know you spike
them into the ground the only stand of
possible what what is on junk rats back
here for the wheel cuz we see some
spikes may see some some like kind of
like handles of some sort operas you
know I'm gonna look up what a cricket
like wicket looks like it looks like
there's the lifeguard McCree which is
the one that I'm I'm trying to get I'm
going for this it's got a whistle and
everything what's it say on the whistle
I wish I could zoom in Oh what's this
and is that like it so I think this is
like high tides something I can't read
it I think that that that's actually the
cricket wicket it's a week yeah yeah
they look wooden a lot of these photos
because you got there's a wickets right
there actually the the ones that you
place on top oh yeah real them there you
go the Internet
what a beautiful oh I get it now that's
the point of the game yeah to knock them
over
oh wow I've learned a lot about any
sport today just now that was cool
we got Mercy's I got this one from the
loop box Aiden says it's a rip tyre yes
we know it's a rip tyre come on you just
like what is it like the the hayseed one
is like the haystack tire don't you mock
us
Reapers yeah Birds this is also the
other one that I kind of want to get did
that keep though he's like he's like the
daredevil but like the daredevil 76 but
it's cool version
Billy steel you can get all these skins
for free on Twitch prime that's right
cuz you get a free gold you get one free
gold in that well that well that it's a
automatic legendary not to say that you
can't get other Legendary's yeah I don't
know if that's true so yes technically
you could get any one of these yeah
grillmaster
best skin ever oh my god strictly for
the socks and sandals you got a little
watch right here he's got the cloth here
he's got a sidearm behind him reminds me
of my father
he keeps whenever he grills he's got a
paper towel in his pocket and all times
it's a good grill must yeah I don't know
what it is but let me know in the
comments does he have the socks and
sandals too no he doesn't he's not a
shoe be shades to the shades in the gray
hair like that gun those is good oh it's
like I was looking at this part I was
thinking of like something like a like a
torch like a flamethrower kind of thing
well I think that would be like living
but looks like it's just like the hot
coils here they make like grills or look
at this it's alright so it's not fear
well it's a it's a can though it's
this wheel on the ground and then it
heals you okay I'm buying this right now
[ __ ] wait should I that's risky I really
want you we have another 54-51 loot
boxes left and there's a high
possibility if Joey makes this purchase
right now we will get that skin I think
you wait till the end
should I start opening she opened up 25
more yes
well do 25 more fingers all right
everyone good juju
let's get grill master I got a nice no
no all right that's cool surprised I
didn't get that one last time that was
common when I believe Wow a hundred
thousand people in front of someone kept
is Marcus's a hundred thousand that's a
lie I don't believe well it can get up
it can get pretty pretty high I've had
like 20,000 some point love you wolf and
twitch a salt rifle with the salt mode
nice nice someone's asking what's that
cylinder that was the wait hold on
hippity-hop what the heck I think we've
gotten now for count'em for regular
Gold's in - no I got the main skin I
hate that some cheese bro well at least
I'm not getting duplicates well actually
in this case I might appreciate it just
oh look it's the old one yeah sure give
me that one thanks
like any oil just gets did give you a
good amount of gold at least and now
it's less that so it's like you gotta
pick one or the other really yeah you
know goob just because you got six gold
it doesn't mean it's good get those gold
skins
Legendary's or any of you guys currently
playing on PC maybe having some luck in
the loot box game here let us know and
don't forget I said it earlier don't
forget to subscribe
since yeah sure let's mccrane you should
just subscribe because of a head I'm
putting this on right now I'm never
taking this off what do you think his
stunt thing is what is it that he throws
in the stun now was it like okay so what
if it's the flash no well that well
that's his gun um so usually he has like
his flash bangs on the side but he has
like water balls here we say oh [ __ ]
it's him
you throw sand in his eyes that would be
hilarious but it might just be like the
same animation but oh I don't know I
have to I have to find out like nice the
guard backpack yeah it's good I still
want to see what his whistle says but
I'll figure that later and he has a
toothpick instead of a cigar he's got
some straws oh yeah I heard about that I
thought I heard you mention that to
someone earlier and I literally I guess
it's not like a trademark thing I had
these same bathing suits like the same
logo the red yeah they're gonna give you
like trademark like guard did you have
the typical like the no never like right
on the edge of the noon everyone every
matter so like
victory pose oh yeah this is the the
other hat or the how intro I got this
one earlier but see now it's glowing
well it's because I it's a duplicate
right but earlier I don't think your
duplicates were grunt we're glowing you
know how like that's easy to signify
yeah no actually nice I saw a few of
them like that it might just be like I
didn't actually go into it yeah take a
look pistol oh that's I would say I have
a question what is he doing in that just
wait he's right he's like yeah he's
waiting for someone to come challenge
him America got that one I still rock
that one proud to be American three says
it's I tied yeah we're gonna be getting
that a lot well that's new yeah cuz that
wasn't around last year put that one on
guess he got duplicate here yeah it's
not as glowy I noticed yes wait is it
wait it doesn't say duplicate though it
just gives me gold on the floor I don't
know it's confusing
are you doing some shady stuff with
these duplicates it's Jessica three says
please go into practice range and see if
Mercy's new skin changes her old voice
that's actually a really good idea I
think we should do that yeah cuz it's
that kid I don't put that one on I was a
good one Oh what the heck it's a summer
game spray I was like okay that's for
all heroes
c33 looks okay we've got six more to go
here just back from the comments it
sounds like you should not restart your
game have you're already in the queue
that's a very good idea so don't don't
quit don't ever leave don't don't don't
turn off your computer leave it on for
the next three weeks oh wait I already
have that oh that was last year's I
couldn't get that one they're a bunch
that I didn't get last year that I'm
kind of excited to pick up now
got that one again death is everywhere
is that oh wow it's dark very morbid uh
yep
so it's over yet skin but you guys
should subscribe cuz GameSpot is alive
every day every weekend
11 a.m. Pacific we play a lot of cool
games
Liz James says so many people here to
see Nick margarita it is true that's not
true whatsoever
ah but yet like this video because Joey
look at him he trying I'm dug deep into
his pockets and purchased these
beautiful lovely loot boxes for you out
of his own bank account so you should
definitely give a life for that uh this
one again yeah I didn't get that one
last year well it's still here if you if
you wanted together yeah so this is your
chance
big chance all right so I got 25 boxes
left let's go into the training mode
real quick and we'll check out Mercy's
yeah periscope Perry is oh it says high
tide patrol on his uh his whistle that's
actually awesome that's pretty cool so
we got Mercy's right here and so like
some lefur oh yeah her ultimate lines
have changed in the past pretty the end
of the whatever it is I think these two
guys get hit pretty good guys right here
yeah all right heal them up will you
shoot alex says they should have made
road hog the speedo I agree that
would've been home row dog is my main so
that was been really funny
who can I res though can actually raise
those guys up there here if they get to
my killed I don't do they ever kill this
guy okay so wait listen
no same same thing same not even for a
price what was for price that's the the
devil one okay I'm pretty sure like I
remember always hearing I was like wait
why is it different here because it's
not like if it's still she still says
the heroes never died
yeah but then again you have the
Halloween one where it's my servants
never die so that's that's the same so
let me go back yeah we're getting some
some requests well actually chat what
would you prefer should we play some
Lucille Ball or should we have Joey try
out some of the new skins pretty
hilarious looks like have a very dinky
gun it's like because it's a flare gun
but it's still like I really thought as
we Sam I know I've been hilarious
is any different I can't imagine it
being that way let us let us know in the
chat would you rather eat some plastic
hose look at this straw hat each said
high noon I just like the straw hat like
going down a little further it's so high
noon it's not it's not high tide yeah we
can do one more time try it but I'm
almost positive it won't Lucille Ball
they want Joey ball Joey ball yeah I
don't play that anymore
oh it's too junk rats
you know they were talking about [ __ ]
junk rats like recently and they wanna I
think from what I've heard they want to
decrease the time on that mine right
there um they want to give them like
better mobility but jeez priests the
damage I think like I think I heard like
they right now it's at eight seconds for
the cooldown but they want to decrease
it to the floor so you'd be like flying
around the map like most of the time
yeah I think that'd be pretty cool yeah
I guess when you put it that way
okay let's the time
normal whoa where you going CGP get
anyone elses I don't think so right
nope so many requests though for some
Lucille Ball Lucille Ball all right
Lucille Ball it is ooh look at this
oh yeah that's a good shot right there I
don't think it's Rita yeah
those got to be I feel like those have
to be the top three skins for everyone's
like favorites well you got let us know
in the comments what do you guys think
are you a fan or one of these three or
do you prefer the dirt bike Reaper or
who else
Percy's sombras scuba diver junk rats
cricket Mercy's Greek goddess mmm while
we're searching let's see if there's any
like highly interesting mr. just any any
emotes and okay well I guess we'll do
that in a second
JJJ tetes is trihard not really any need
to he didn't get anything skin no
highlight intro maybe an emote possibly
he's my main so I'm always bummed out
when he doesn't get anything ah goalie
Oh not doing so that way goob that was
on me boob our resident expert says oh
she says that his favorites are where's
your comment right
so we'll twitch I'm sure chats going
really fast mercy as his top then widow
then Joe crab really what
that's embarrassing joy no it went right
way no it's embarrassing I hit it
what happened well look at this
a lot of space between the ball
embarrassing oh ok balls over there uh
please oh my god just in Valencia I
think it is out for consoles right now
it just sounds like everyone's trapped
in it Q hell wow those are my shot that
was my shot say that was the other team
it's a top cheddar right there okay yeah
don't forget we are oh this guy knows
what he's doing
GUP says Nick why don't you play on PC
yeah there you go with the assists the
simple reality and simple truth why I
don't play on PC is because I don't have
a PC at home I only have a PC here at
work have you been like like because if
you jump from PC ps4 or like vice versa
so you're gonna have to redo all your
all your skins and all your progress
that's you and I've like prestige twice
and it's like I don't know there's like
a big commitment to just start over we
have more so just because I keep I
wouldn't be able to play at home I know
sad life
the other way FCC at home mind blowing
sorry
get up on them walls try and there we go
I'm gonna try to get back into the
periscope chat one last time
bad Simon Says how long the Summer Games
live
it's gonna be live until the 28th I
think you said so like three weeks three
weeks just twenty guys playing so so we
get two weeks half all right I'm gonna
play goalie be jumping around here guys
good ooh two minutes long time
that was a laser back to yeah I know I
should have hit it upwards
Jannetty if you'd like to see some skins
and you're on youtube you can scrub all
the way back down here oh nice yeah I
guess cherry picking real hard actually
just heard his teammates writing it up F
to Jeremiah a hundred thousand people
ahead of them
don't be rude we know you love Joey he's
a sick the sick is going ah ha I don't
know if I pronounced that right can you
show the sombre skin we showed it
towards the beginning of the story all
right got my turbo boost sound barrier
let's go I don't know I kind of like the
old way where it was done oh yeah
all I got is cheap it for that nice oh
you did me you mean the yeah I like the
ultimate last time with the magnets but
it was so funny I know but I think
that's why they changed it because it
was like kind it's kind of cheap yeah oh
it was cool I think it's important for
someone to play goalie here
in oh my god sounds like they're getting
close only five or two people in front I
cannot carry scope out sorry if you're
up for a scope hi how are you hi how are
you I can't figure out the chat 3-3 35
seconds let's go
okay they got it you got to olds over
there come on guys go oh you hear that
musics well I'm actually nervous
oh well that guy is old nice get it out
of there oh you serious always doing so
well
it's like zoo
three seconds maybe all right baby
maybe arc scoop says in yo face
well let's run it back
is this the player to play game of the
winning goal is this the winning one oh
it's uh yeah this
oh no times earlier
there were better ones what about all my
saved what happened to those and vote
for me
r.i.p to the dream says swift parrot
Lucille Ball competition is gonna be so
fun one assists four saves seven
interceptions three golds he didn't get
the gold medal for winning this
screenshot it's gonna be my wallpaper
maybe somebody was asking about emotes
emotes yes yeah we should check those I
got one because you got it yeah so she
got the beach ball one here oh it's
equipped this is the old one from last
year and I found a boxing one doing
nothing Ginji no Hahn's Oh Lucille might
know that's all yes old one oh that's
funny great that's funny me not that
reminds me have you ever been to what's
it called it's like Christmas in July
it's a it's a mini-golf course at Disney
World
that's what it reminds I haven't heard
of it like all the Disney characters are
wearing like lifeguard stuff and then
there's snow in July it's like Florida
though right it's always it's always
gonna be warm there even in December
like there are many emotes actually I
haven't run into a new one yet that's
pretty surprising
nope Wow the Torbjorn tracer maybe no
yeah I mean Nuria has the only one we've
seen being been on uh looks like she's
the only one I have that's weird
25 characters only one new emote hmm
somber didn't have one no sure then we
just went the wrong yeah we just I just
went through all looked for the likes of
him have the the the logo but it's the
old one the other one can't be old cuz
she wasn't around then yeah so she's the
only one that has a new one for this
event that's weird like no the new
characters have until Sombra no or so
yeah I don't know maybe I might have
putting on when I got it let's put on
the here we go the beach ball wow that
face is so creepy with that we that we
there are a couple of highlight intro
zone like far as once again far just
don't yeah and then there's who had one
Hanzo had one of them it was target
practice so sick Robin Hood knit yeah
people are asking was there an actual
update or did you just hop in a queue to
get in there were there wasn't a day
there was a small update um in the
client like right before I jumped in
light ask guys do the ps4 version have
the summer skin they do yes it's a it's
identical to the PC everything that
you're seeing here is also there so
don't worry you get this hot bod I
expected more oh boy this look look at
our setting now we're on
we're on the beach or beachside at the
end of this if he doesn't get it he's
gonna be buying those once I get it
right here this was like tased problem
before you really just get this guy the
river or gambler McCree I don't get it
during events you shouldn't go there you
go as long as it's new that's what
that's what I'm most worried about it's
kinda like don't those remind you of
like the 50's sunglasses
yeah like the big frames like doing tips
bring them back bring let's bring those
sunglasses back those are sick what
yours the flips I don't know where I put
those I took them with me to e3 so two
more and I could wear them and I don't
know where I put them
I got lost on the show floor somewhere
maybe you know what I bet you if
everyone hit the like and subscribe
button we would get a ton of those and
if you guys subscribe I'll give you a
shout out by the way this is the third
time I've gotten this skin dress Ebert
says first time watching live hello
greetings welcome to the stream welcome
to the chat I don't get what that is you
can't kid oh man that's good weird and
for those of you who need
what is that the bunny huh all right so
we'll go finish off the recipes boxes
and then let's go jump into a regular
match see if we can show off some of the
skins there yeah yeah we don't
okay so speaking of Widow we've actually
had a featured um by the UK's Dave
Jewett hmm which he talked about like
the amount of heroes and overwatch and
one of the things that I was looking at
one I was looking at some of my least
played characters in the game because he
mentioned that to me and Widow is
actually my least played out everyone
not including doofus gold by the way
non-clean doofus so Widow is like all
the way at the bottom with only like 40
minutes played yeah I'm pretty sure all
40 of those minutes I mean a lot of when
I would I'm distracted not paying
attention so anyway yeah it's all 40 of
those minutes are from like great like
mystery heroes where I'm forced to play
her yeah so yeah well it's not gonna be
pretty
the super gamer says can you see my
comment I can your comment mother box
legend says notice me I've noticed you
Vita says he's subbed thank you for the
subscribe welcome to the show just
speeding through these who do boat which
is said it only took 90 boxes but we
finally got some good ones oh we got
nine left so that's good pray for me
kept cats as hi love your bids thank you
we appreciate that
and yet yeah off that comment especially
you guys should definitely check out
Dave's kind of feature about are there
too many heroes I think I know where
Joey and I stand on this I don't think
Victor enough and I think they can go I
feel like it will get to a certain point
because he'll know like blizzard's very
meticulous about balance in the game
it's like they're constantly retooling
like they have I don't know if they get
to a point where they have like so many
they kind of they might make more other
heroes I don't think they would do that
so they might put a cap somewhere along
lines of like 50 it's a lot because
running at what 25 they're only a 25 and
they they've said they've set outright
that they don't want to have more they
don't they they only want to do about
three maybe four a year yeah you're just
like dang you just got three dupes right
there really yeah yeah the dupes are
starting to roll in oh there we go
from these hundred loop boxes that's why
justice said he subbed thank you he's
she's her subbed Vito wants to know
what's her favorite event I'm sticking
with Halloween Halloween my favorite
Halloween was good I really liked it I
did like the Christmas one I think I
really liked it because like in the UM
like they redid Kings row like now I
thought that was really good like I like
the way that they decorate all the
stages plus may snowball offensive is
essentially SWAT from like halo which is
sick that was that's actually my
favorite mode the I mean the wave based
thing for Halloween was cool Chuck and
Steen's revenge mm-hmm but the pvp may
snowball the second last one is my last
one all right boys and girls this is it
here we go it's gonna just be a like one
rare that's it
hmm at least I got mostly what I wanted
was there anything that I missed
actually you've got those three say you
got soldier or Reaper Reapers only one
so I got I got mercies and sombras I
it's okay I was not crazy I'm not crazy
over it but it looks pretty cool maybe I
like her hair on this one maybe I'll
hold off on buying just buying hers
because I don't really she's actually my
second lease played really yeah yeah
she's pretty good in that
Cree's got his junk rat but sure the one
everyone it's waiting for
oh man that beer can though vehicon or
the heal up can diet fuel up all right
let's do this let's go into quick play
hopefully you get some soldier divine
vibe says noticed me we've noticed you
how are you Cassie wants to know if
anyone's playing on ps4 that is a good
question I am interested to see if
anyone's been able to get through queue
hell and get in there I actually like
the Great Britain one better than the
other one yeah I wish I'd gone that one
last year but I missed it yeah let's go
mythical orbit says welcome the super
gamer says he sub
like his watch mr. Glover you welcome
back alright wait what Emo's who I have
I have the I have the pushup someone so
all I can do that real quick
oh yeah one-armed dead push-ups dad
push-ups dad that's some dad strength
right those got dances dance
that's a sad dance - it's okay let's go
my taste wants to know what the New York
is oh yeah okay mode yeah it's Lucille
Ball and then the ranked Lucille Ball um
I don't think that Blizzard favors PC to
be honest I think it's just I feel like
it's them
yeah it might be easier for them to like
roll it out on this their servers first
yeah
you know it's interesting you know all
the kind of hoops you have to jump
through oh yes she has a lifeguard
scheme come on Jonah thank you for the
subscribe welcome to game spa we live
stream every day every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific come on
even though today is a fantastic stream
better roll up will be more awesome
stuff to come JPMorgan's that's a great
name give me just a bank and Vedek
tricks am I saying that right
yeah be dexterous how do you get the dot
set up the cross on the cut all online
yeah I just changed it the crosshairs
you can change them too
I think you can do custom crosshairs oh
yeah you can make it like super thick if
you want for whatever reason yep like if
you just go into the options and under
gameplay weight controls so has the
circle cross there instead of default
yep but you can also like change it like
you can make the thickness and make it
super thick if you want yeah no I feel
better that way else is there the
opacity turn down and up dot size you
can make it super big super small you
also change the color too so blond oh no
it's not a toothpick oh I know it is I'm
sick did he shave too is this little
stubble is it like it's yes it's a lot
of a closer shave than it usually is let
me know in the comments what is a mask
Joey this question - what is your
favorite kind of popsicle and/or Beach
ice cream you know how they have like
the beach carts were yes ice cream what
is your favorite my a really long time I
will say that when I was younger I don't
know how many people remember these but
the the push pops the flintstones once
those were really good like they were
they were they were extremely messy they
got all over the place because it's just
like melted yes like just hardly
anything worthy of like actually being
pushed out in a cylindrical form was
bomb pops I think oh yeah they were they
own that were they the popsicles own
ones yeah
I used to I used to get at like Costco
with my mom I used to get like just
frozen sticks just like frozen literally
frozen ice oh you mean the the otter
pops yes otter pops those are yeah I
love those some people said some people
said milk crazy ah Gubar they called
firecrackers I didn't know the other
rocket ones huh I think you're right I
think you're right cube you know what
the other one that was really good was
it was only at Disney there's only ad is
in the Mickey well yeah those are so
those are the best I get them at the
time but um it was like a we've only
happened for like one summer at like
Disneyland at Disney World and they were
called it was uh it was a
what's up qudoos that was the name of
the pop it's Anna doozy yeah and it used
to twist
[Music]
does anyone the chat remember that it
was called a what sucka doozy if you
look it up it was a good it was like a
Disney exclusive ice pop or something
like that now my go-to yeah
tell me your favorite ice cream Patrick
I gotta do this all this hair is
different to each block yeah but it's
like look at it look at it it's like the
beach look sea salt ice cream never
heard of that pineapple why he saw like
caramel is I don't know I've never had
that before
so what'd you guys think of macri's
flare-gun pretty good it does look like
a dinky gun you know I mean but it's
still deadly
ah divine vibes as I know what you're
talking about he remembers only be here
whoa whoa whoa whoa they still make goop
says that the kingdom heart parts with
them
what is home Oh
Magnum boy we just destroyed the forms
creamsicle why you guys wrecked out
meanwhile we're over here just talking
about ice cream
yes position agario push pops those were
my favorite who looks like Larry the
lobster McCree oh yeah yeah Jason oh the
boys with ice cream pineapple ice cream
at Disney is the best it's the best and
I I mixed on it because okay it's I
think no I ain't saying that I don't
look as good I just don't see the hype
over it
doh well I think in the context of
Disneyland that's why it's so good
because it's so freakin hot there most
of the time and you need like a cold
treat this is like supposedly the best
ice cream or it's the ultimate girls
reading I think if if you get the the
one with the pineapple juice that's that
I think that's a little bit too sweet
like after by the time you get to it
you're just like okay if that's enough I
agree but it is good I will say like but
I don't see why specifically at
Disneyland it tastes better than if you
get go to like a mall I think if I think
a casual I think anything tastes better
[Music]
even the pretzels you like oh it's so
good it's like the same pretzel you have
anywhere yeah like I was Mickey shaped
or a lot if you get you know like the
pickles there or the pineapple spears I
get those all the time the fruit carts
in like Adventureland what I didn't know
that yeah let's let's pick someone new
we got Ginji or I mean we got soldier
and got a lot of really we'll play that
after someone picked
already I'm surprised there's no tanks
we've got new skins I'll go with mercy
actually uh what happened to Widow wool
will hop into a little lucia ball after
sick widow play right it's not gonna be
pretty
I don't get the gun the gun definitely
looks different and it definitely is a
purpose I just I don't know it's not
like it's not a flare gun it's not a
grill what do you guys think it's got
like a wooden it says look at what says
on it it says by surface Hall you want
to look that up see what means in French
[Music]
French lost girl was that what is that
what it
very bad friend I mean oh girl oh god
I'm not I'm just really distracted right
now you thought setting up at all it's
gonna be right here this is this what
your theory can see
three fatal kiss fatal Elias says thank
you GUP says emo Tom Joel I got there we
go this is not how you play Widow in
case you guys are watching this for any
hot tips okay no more that yep Miko is
right by their means kisses so it means
fatal kiss has everybody and I'll chat
doing on key updates hurt some people
oh my some people got in I'm seeing a
lot of people that said
like only point in the in the in the
triple digits now instead of like the
quadruple or Quinn double digits yeah so
a lot of people are saying like get no
scoped says it's a pirate gun
I get higher it well I don't buy me that
doesn't I guess yeah I know weird that
it fits that she's given that even
though because she has like a beach like
a beach like a beach chair like a wooden
beach chair you know seem to get strange
go do this oh my god going way too far
man Jason Tavares a sad day one of my
main characters gets games I agree
please whispering I can read that ps4
works just be patient
that's a testament to waiting in the
queue I'm not I don't play Murcielago
[Music]
yum yum yum
yeah I'm not I'm not sure I can get on
board the this swimsuit time now flaming
Raptor just made a sick idea I mean he
said that it's it's a water gun it's
definitely not but how funny would that
have been if it was like a like a super
soaker looker like for who for for widow
Widow yeah I can I'm done for the night
kinda wish save with loot like given
that the headband giving that to someone
else or just like a water gun in general
oh come on a lot of people are saying
that the
hello trace here with water guns that
would be funny just shoot the water yes
people are saying no I've never seen
this mercy skin it is it's brand new
annual ham new what's your favorite
character
mine is road hog Joey's arrested ya
think oh yeah 45 points let me use it Oh
Super Soaker game-mode all weapons
replacement son oh my god you got a
tweet at Blizzard these are good ideas
what what would it be like though like
you wouldn't die right cuz there has to
be like some kind of like
I don't know how to really use the Rings
with mercy I mean like when to use it
specifically Wow
Joey's really good at this game I was
trying to show off someone like I'm not
healing my team new game someone really
high up
who's that
yeah there are so many things that they
could have done like water guns and
water related yeah like more summer
themed things instead of just like the
Olympics
I do love that diva skin the police
officer on Oh No thank you
building for a double of seven cents
when we play Lucille Ball we can play
after this
um you know it's tough to kind of blame
to lose your roofing slow on consoles
cause it still being like yeah yeah it's
tough to blame them though to be honest
like it's not only God like they're
doing with their own yeah like they're
having to go on to a bunch of like other
hoops to have to jump through I guess
hey is the old Summer Games diva
available in this event to hit on yes it
is
all the old uh all the old skinnies from
last year summer games are available now
and they're cheaper to hassey says yes i
blame for these pc players very Oh what
the hell
I just got annihilated by doing this
it's still tough I'm in the same boat
I am a constable overwatch player so
guys Oh No
[Music]
we lose not happening this time all
right I think should we end it there I
think a couple we a couple Lucille Ball
you want to do one more Lucille Ball and
then we call it let's do one more
Lucille Ball summer skins yes those I
have the jazzy one but I have this one
right here yeah like I won Bob Jones
says it would be nice if it was on
switch it would it would but I I would
never plant handheld mode like a game
like this it's pretty difficult yeah I
think the most like the farthest thing
for me is like splatoon blue team is
like the most intense shooters me oh my
god play on the switch I actually
haven't played a lot more splatoon and
overwatch lately I know same here which
has been a total flip-flop for me summer
games though
big cheese that's so mature of you he
said I'ma be more patient
oh god need to be a little bit closer
that's my problem
right on the edge look at this
okay well why is it zubeidaa the ball so
much I hurt my eyes so what do you guys
thinking what is your favorite new or
old summer games game over
let us know
and if you like Lucy ball hit the like
goosey ball Lucille Ball oh all I need
marques you buy loot boxes we did Joey
opened about a hundred and three of them
they are earlier wrapped the stream it
sounds like Lucille Ball competitive's
having some issues
[Music]
just going nuts it took two in the
corner well that's super well there's
like oh man got around them
skill bros how you doing welcome to the
chat again guys don't forget hit that
like button definitely hit the subscribe
button Joey
John Luke they often stream on Friday
Fridays they do some funny stuff we have
Peter and Rob oh my god he didn't Rob
often play some some funny games with
Zelda and other stuff like that but it's
always here on GameSpot yeah yeah make
sure you guys hit the subscribe button
so you're notified when the guys go live
and what game they're playing it's every
single day every single weekday 11:00
a.m. Pacific you don't want to miss it
it's all good stuff dang I thought
they're gonna finish that go out that
bar sounds like everyone in the Lucille
Ball competitive not playable it's not
enough to save it though and you do we
need go we got a school yeah there you
go to to one minute to play
bro Kenji hello how are you
all right so should I go should I say on
defense here thank these guys I'm doing
pretty good right probably push up a
little bit oh I feel like it's been over
on their side yeah more they've been
like scrambling a lot they've been oh my
god oh my god I am the worst might even
my fault kind of told him to push out
sorry oh I want to see this all right 45
seconds Redemption here you got to push
the ball goalies coming out pulling the
goalie oh my god oh that's got potential
what happened was it me no well you
won't be able to tell because it zooms
in on the ball I don't know Bob John
says terrible goalie terrible that's not
true
yep Bob says you knocked it in god damn
it
redemption oh I think we have to play
one more I don't think you end on a no
goal your blast goal can't be a known by
fine one more
that'll because that game only took like
three minutes four minutes this will be
it boys and girls again if you want to
watch this take a look at the front of
the stream you can scrub to the front
good luck to everyone that's in queue
don't worry we believe in you you'll get
there eventually eventually have
patience patience is a virtue let's get
a win to finish yourself oh yeah what
are you doing
gotta get a win to finish or at least a
goal
I like his Brazilian soccer skin better
than the Summer Games it's cool which
one I like this one better than like the
generic Summer Games one this string oh
this one yeah yeah this one's a lot
better yeah that's cool it's cool cuz
they use the actual like country's
colors yeah their national team I
thought they would do that for more of
the characters like I thought they would
have like like one for symmetrization
Lea for Symetra was from the anniversary
yeah she didn't get a new one this time
around though
all right here we go let's do this
did you hear the voice the voice guy
when you're here in Sydney is ah yeah Oh
shouldn't do that okay I'm not gonna not
gonna push it into my own goal this time
[Music]
corner punch that
this guy he just doesn't want on the
stream that's what it is
how'd this happen oh just missed it just
a whiff
Carson dodge you said gotta end with the
wind
hey no we we win earlier yeah it was uh
some hot gold yeah it was overtime win I
think it was a pretty good one Oh God
dang starting to see some people are
getting kicked
oh and then they have to restart the
client yeah back into the queue yeah it
sucks I'm I've got my fingers crossed
for you guys and it's just a little it's
just a little nope
no formality that that Blizzard is
finishing up these things and they'll be
ready to go oh man right when I leave
reminds me of that Brazil Germany game
and the World Cup nice again get that
out of here no seriously get that oh my
god
that was a laser I want to see the
replay of that all right see you get it
out yeah like okay I'm fine now hang his
own it was way faster all right let's
try no more goals
no more goes on my on my end yeah hey
like that what the heck why is it going
so fast
I like had you switch your skin
alright Alton don't waste it hey where
is it here we go go
oh alright see we gonna I'm gonna happy
now I told you that's it go
that's you dead know what I know that's
that's weird I think slightly broken
it's all right that guys are going in
alright minute forty four can the boys
do it get a little comes we can oh come
on
whoa whoa whoa let you get it oh my god
come on
oh yes that's another one in put it in
eight seconds just it just this is going
back and forth right now oh please
oh you're ahead of every poem put in oh
damn it
lost cause
going going going Oh ten seconds ten
seconds that you're going that was the
other guy's rolling here we go baby ten
my goalie oh it's over there
ten nine eight put it in seven six five
oh god no close that was good that was
good that was good one well anyway thank
you guys for joining us my thanks to
Joey for killing it oh we so we got
played the game at least is it you this
is the one that brought us closer oh I
think yeah right here like punch it in
thank you guys enjoyed it again if you
guys want to check out the skins that
was earlier in the stream so you can
scrub back and take a look at all the
skins with us Lucille Ball you tried out
these three yeah we actually got most of
the skins now I think we got all the
skins except for Reaper I guess both you
know we got all the skins that we wanted
so you want to see those you can yeah
like he's like Nick said you can scrub
back yeah but look at all of them just
don't watch it like the first 75 blue
boxes
last 25 those are the good ones those
really good but yeah thank you guys for
joining us hopefully you get out of
queue hell soon and you can start
getting in there up into Lucille Ball
matches or so so thank you guys and
we'll see you
[Music]
[Music]